We are 450 million people in the European Union,
that's a lot of people to feed and for that we
need agriculture that is productive.
Remember that in order to grow one of the main nutrients a plant needs,
nitrogen,
in the 20th century a method was found to recover nitrogen in an artificial way
and to make chemical fertilizers to increase agricultural yields.
It worked very well and normally exploded.
The problem,
shut up,
the problem is that today we realize that chemical fertilizers
are destroying our environment.
How do we stop using chemical fertilizers without destroying our agriculture?
Well,
instead of going to get nitrogen artificially,
we are going to ask nature to give us a little help oh it's too beautiful.
In fact in nature there is a great thing called legumes,
legumes,
legumes that we know.
It will be peas,
beans,
lentils,
it will also be a family of plants that is able to live in symbiosis with bacteria
called rhizobiomes and rhizobiomes,
they have this capacity to recover the nitrogen that is in the air because our air
is made of eighty percent nitrogen and to put them and
to put this nitrogen in the leaves,
the stems,
the roots and the legumes from this moment on,
the legumes become a source of organic nitrogen
that can be used in agriculture.
What is culture rotation?
In fact it is an agricultural method which will consist in alternating between
cultures of legumes and cereals on the same surface from one year to the other
because in fact the legumes we said that they had nitrogen they have this capacity
to leave the nitrogen behind them after their passage which is super useful of
the blow for the cultures which come after that that is to say the cereals the
limit to that is that only 10 of the surface European agriculture is enough to
cover the needs of the population in legumes that it is useless to produce more
legumes because if we produce more legumes certainly we have more nitrogen for
the cereals but we waste all the legumes that we produce which is a bit stupid
and for that we need to have a second method to obtain organic nitrogen in fact
there will be other types of legumes it is fine to be the clover the holy hay
the alfalfa the lotiers it is legumes that we do not know we would
not like but that the cattle consume.
The idea is going to be to give these legumes to our farms and to recover
the nitrogen through their droppings so it is the poop of the cows of the
farm where I work that was applied on the market gardening soil.
Yes,
cows for the climate are not incredible because
they fart and put metal in the air.
They are nevertheless extremely important for organic farming.